George I have to be different my grandpa
is who he is
um I'm in Nashville where everyone
there's this a machine now you know
music grow is a machine they go with
what's working they want someone who's
going to do exactly what's someone else
has done
um it's it's not about the artist or the
person it's more about the song and if
it's gonna go well and they're just
gonna keep putting pop country on the
country radio that's what people want to
hear and it seems to be that's what
people want to hear
hello everyone hola Mis Amigos you're
listening to oh my God
hola With Me George
Georgia Carolina
you know George is oh I'm sure he's
around here somewhere what's his name
George Lopez George Lopez oh my God omg
omg
uh well my favorite beer to drink these
days is All Day IPA
watch out that's good that's the IPA
George if you want the lager that's the
other one uh I no I know but
they're great because it's just a little
bit of alcohol in it so you can drink
all day long and it even has a car on it
so you could even drink and drive with
this stuff
what if it has a car on it
like
has a car with a canoe on the top you
could go canoeing all right
there's a there's some I don't know you
know you know
driving you see I mean clearly I mean
it's not a you can't take the position
that it's okay but
um
it was way it was much different uh
before
um when did it change girl you were you
were a law enforcement when did you see
DUIs
and these should be called 502s what do
they call the Nashville
DWIs
yeah DUI
grab it under the inputs right the 502
was section in the vehicle code 6502 was
drunk driving
uh they didn't that that stuff wasn't
really prevalent in the 70s you know
we're after other stuff DUIs became
prevalent out here when uh
mad uh Mothers Against truck drivers
start pushing the issue yeah you don't
want to I heard dads against drunk
drivers I heard how come because Dad's
gonna go they have to care though right
because that Mom told them you sit there
we'll take care of it I heard a damn
drunks against mad mothers
um let's see there's so many places to
stay
um
when you think of yourself
musically
uh how far can you go back to when you
felt like it in your in your whole being
you know some kids you know go to church
and sing and you know some kids are like
I'm not going to say I mean singing is
maybe the most vulnerable for any
performer at at any time in their career
I don't care if it's a wedding I don't
care if you're just like singing a
little bit there's always
there's always a bit of risk with a
singer because of the tone and the notes
and it's it's just it's it's such a
concise
art that there when somebody hits a bad
note you could just look at each other
and be like oh [ __ ] did you ah ooh you
know and uh some kids are shy when
they're growing up and they're just like
no I don't want to do that and then I
feel because of your lineage that I
believe uh that genetically you can be
uh pass along a talent uh from
generations and and through generations
I've seen it firsthand I mean I've
witnessed a family that was Musical and
I admire it uh because you know it's
almost like when you buy a car it's
standard equipment like you have it
whether you use it or not is up to the
person
um when did you find
um yourself
feeling that
Musical
kind of
where where it got you in the gut
where it spoke to you
I was young I've always written little
Melodies in my head I feel like
that's the
is the internet okay yeah you're coming
through it's going out okay good
um when I was a kid I was always writing
Melodies in my head I feel like as a
songwriter that's the best that I can
bring to the table of songwriting with
Melodies a catchy Melody and lyrics and
I remember being in my room I was
probably eight years old and I had this
dry erase marker board and I was
pretending to teach these stuffed
animals that I had I was pretending to
be a teacher and I remember going I
think I could be a teacher one day and
then immediately was like no I'm gonna
be a singer and I'm gonna play guitar
like my grandpa and sing on stage so I
just knew that's what I wanted to do I
didn't take steps to do that until I
actually had children and I was stuck at
home with three little kids and I just
started picking up the guitar and
figuring out these Melodies that I had
been writing my whole life but I had
always been involved in voice lessons
ends show choir you know taking guitar
lessons uh all throughout you know
school and high school piano lessons I
was always drawn to music for sure do
you know who her grandfather is sure do
did some uh research well first of all
the last name of Nelson you know and
then you everything says granddaughter
of Willie Nelson uh your songwriting
that song free when you talked about
your kids and what you wrote the song
free about and I was listening to it
very very catchy very nice
thank you I appreciate that yeah how did
freak let's talk about we'll get to the
wheelie how did free come to you
so I was at home with three little kids
five cats three dogs
two hamsters few birds and I just gotten
divorced and stuck at home but I because
even though I was stuck at home with all
these responsibilities I feel felt
totally free of that situation and
that's how the song came about and then
after the last couple
of years we've had with the pandemic and
everyone being stuck at home I really
thought everyone could maybe relate to
it as we're starting to get back out and
be a little more normal again
um so that's why I released it I I was
planning on not releasing it and it just
being a song that I would play at
Acoustic shows or something but then
really felt like everyone could relate
to it and I I want to put songs out that
I feel like people can relate to you
know I don't I don't like just write a
song about something but I try to pick
things that are that happen in life and
write a song about that situation
because I feel like if I've seen it
happen then somebody else has probably
seen something like that too and they
can relate to it
so yeah I think there's a lot of weight
to
um life you know and and if you have an
outlet like being able to
you know write a song or you know in my
instance you know
um to be able to I used to write uh
jokes on uh on a on an old uh water and
power envelope or envelopes that my
grandmother had you know an old uh
telephone bills and the back of of
envelopes and things like that where it
just seemed to me better than writing I
like journals and I like notebooks I
always I always have I always like pens
but I do like writing on the back of an
envelope or a manila folder or something
that's a little bit more uh down and
rustic you know I always had pens in my
pocket and always had things in my uh
head and things would just pop pop into
my head you know and I thought I
couldn't remember anybody in my family
being remotely amusing or funny or
encouraging or
um
um happy and I thought
um this is a really
uh uh
very disconnected uh family and I think
that the humor of it much like writing
music will come from a sense of of
sadness
you know a sense of
I gotta get the [ __ ] out of here
uh a sense of
um
yeah uh of just uh a situation that was
so heavy that if you didn't pursue
uh a career or an opportunity that was
better than what all my friends were
kind of looking to do in the
neighborhood that that it was not gonna
be a kind of a life well lived I felt
right I think so I understand what
you're saying
um um uh you know
uh uh what are some of the jokes that I
had uh um you know
um let's see
uh camera but but you know I I and there
wasn't a really a lot of
Latino comedians you know and and and
Country I worked out in the early 80s I
worked with a guy named Steve Castro and
this guy was selling cocaine in the
second shift and he was an alcoholic and
he he had a bottle of scope and I
thought I thought [ __ ] people
don't swallow scope they spit it out but
what he had done is put vodka in the
scope and added green food coloring so
when he it looked like he was using
mouthwash he'd swish it around and then
he'd swallow it and I thought who
swallows scope and but the fact that I
was listening to these country songs
John Anderson
and and all kinds of different stuff and
at first I was like Steve you know can
you we kind of maybe have a day that's
not country in the office but I found
myself listening to Merle Haggard and
Waylon Jennings and there was some uh
you know one of the greatest guitar
player is ever of all time there's a
couple of them one is Glenn Campbell and
one is Roy Clark and all of those guys
that like
I love rock but
country is more compelling their lives
are I mean I talked to Merle Haggard and
he said to me
I killed a man and I was in a blacked
out State and the next morning when they
told me I'd killed a man I didn't
remember killing him and I went to
prison and I did my time and my family
was estranged from me and I was
estranged from them and I saw a
documentary of Merle Haggard and I
thought I got to meet this guy and I met
him and he couldn't have been
a better person or a nicer man
understanding all his flaws and I
thought that's what that's what country
is like countries you're born with your
country in you and I think rock you find
on the road but I think countries you
agree with that that there it's in your
heart it's in your family it's in your
loss and it's in your gain it's a way of
life but it's not a good life
it's a good life but there is a you from
Pain you go you have to right I think
you know what I'm trying to say right
yeah I think uh you know how people say
that a lot of comedians have to have
traumatic paths in order to have this
funny sense of humor
it's kind of the same with country right
you kind of have to have some traumatic
experiences or some drama at least in
order to create these country songs
because a country song usually stems
from sadness right or I mean if we're
talking about real country songs like my
grandpa's songs and Merle Haggard and
Johnny I mean all of those stemmed from
some sort of sadness
yes
and and and and and being young you're
you're
um where do you where do you find your
music going do you think
so I don't I have a really sad song I
wrote called daddy's grave about my
Dad's passing and it it's like song
therapy where you get these things out
that need to be said that you can't say
to anyone with and also you'd feel maybe
kind of stupid if it wasn't in a song
you know yes so did that and when we
would play it out and about everybody in
the audience would get really sad and it
would take three or four songs for me to
see the energy get back up to
dancing and moving with big smiles on
their faces right that I decided I
didn't want to do that song live anymore
you know I just thought that sad songs
were for call
listening or shower listening
oh I made the decision a long time ago
that I want to make people happy I want
them to be on this high for a couple of
weeks after not super sad
but um but yeah I my plan is to let the
songs come to me if if I haven't written
a song in a while or one's not coming to
me then I'll just go take a drive
through the back roads and usually that
I can count on that almost every time to
something will come into my head or
it'll help me out of the writer's block
and you see and you seem to have like
just wait for them to come right and you
seem to have like a free spirit you know
like like your videos and everything you
do you're you're a really kind of a a
free spirit
yeah
thank you I'm trying to be yes yeah uh
um um what are some of the things that
that
um that you've seen live you know you
know uh Lucille Ball used to live in
this neighborhood and like Jack Benny
would go over and all the Cabret Skelton
all Comedians and actors uh who have you
seen I used to always say you know did
you see that person with your own eyes
like I would never imagine growing up
that I would be able to see some of the
people that I've seen with my own eyes
and whenever somebody sees somebody
really very very you know uh a
historical figure in music or in an
actor I always would say not anymore but
I always would say
uh did you see them with your own eyes
and they would say yeah of course but I
just where I came from I couldn't
imagine that somebody would be I mean I
I was I shared a limo with Bob Hope and
and we talked and I would look over and
and see Bob Hope and you know and to me
it was like I saw him with my own eyes
and there he was you know like who do
you remember or what are some of the
things that are so vivid in your memory
that that you're like wow I really got a
chance to do all that
um so my grandpa on his bus that's where
I've seen the most famous people and
it's it's funny because all the kids and
grandkids whenever the famous people
come on the bus we tend to kind of mean
Meander toward the back because we feel
like we're in the way yeah but I
remember I remember Keith Richards
getting up on the bus and uh Vince
Vaughn Rob Thomas
um I remember Kenny Chesney doing stuff
with him oh Cindy Lauper uh it just it
goes on and on but I didn't really hang
out with them of course he entered
produce me to them but I would I would
just go to the back and let them do
their thing and they would just gush on
my grandpa you know right
yeah I mean your grandfather is I mean I
uh interviewed him uh we I hosted Jimmy
Kimmel and he was a guest you know and I
think I met Annie on a plane and been
around uh Willie and then you know uh
Owen and and you know Luke and uh yeah
and and and your grandfather and I
interview uh
uh Woody Harrelson reached out through
my publicist and said tell George that
uh it was great to see Willie laughing
and being Willy like you know it was an
interview but more of a gist of a
conversation you know
yeah yeah I'm sure he enjoys that for
sure I remember meeting Woody Harrelson
also and him and I made a arranged
marriage for our children to get married
I like that I like that uh uh um is uh
is Elvis in your in your in your in your
heart
well yeah I love Elvis but I never you
know I never got he was gone before I
was around but yeah I love Elvis or who
doesn't like Elvis there's some people
that do like there's some people I don't
understand anybody could not I mean if
you think about a guy that uh came from
no place and uh was a hillbilly and and
and even
to this day I mean he died very very
young at 42 but is one name he has to be
the one named person all around the
world
I did yes I didn't appreciate him when I
was younger I I not until I became an
adult and I started appreciating him and
and I turned out to be that I ended up
loving him
um yeah yeah I mean country is that and
explain to everybody that that's that's
listening and watching what how
Nashville became what it's become
oh wow well Music City so the first
recording of music was done in Tennessee
but I think it was kind of more like the
Bristol areas The Carter Family actually
which is who Johnny Cash married into
June Carter Cash
um so the Carter family was the first to
actually record music and
um so then you know they had the Grand
Ole Opry here at the Ryman and it was at
the Ryman Auditorium downtown Nashville
and the back entrance which is the
artist entrance when there was an alley
there that went to tootsies which is the
famous Orchid Lounge Bar it's uh the
only purple building downtown Nashville
and downtown Nashville is only about
four blocks not very big at all and it's
super crowded these days all the time
but uh tootsies is where all the
songwriters would go and hang out and
all the singers would go and hang out
after and before they had to play the
Ryman
so they would pitch people songwriters
would pitch songs that's where my
grandpa pitched crazy to Patsy Cline and
she went recorded it that evening
um that's kind of the uh that's where it
all started the Ryman and the Grand Ole
Opry and actually just a radio show at
the time right and then
now it's um it's not even at the Ryman
anymore which is sad it's but it makes
sense because it needs to house more
people it's now over by the Opryland
hotel and over by the Willie Nelson
Museum
and um it's just huge now it's just uh
you know the the country acts of today
are more
more poppy in my opinion but they try to
keep it uh it's pretty close to country
you know I haven't been able to play it
because you know I have a rock band
right and um we do play acoustic and in
those cases we do sound more like a
country band you know but just haven't
made my Mark at the Granville Opera yet
hope too soon though yeah I like that
you like uh that you like rock you know
um yeah yeah I have to be different
George I have to be different my grandpa
is who he is
um I'm in Nashville where everyone
there's that's a machine now you know
Music Row is a machine they go with
what's working they want someone who's
going to do exactly what's someone else
has done
um it's it's not about the artist or the
person it's more about the song and if
it's gonna go well and they're just
going to keep putting pop country on the
country radio if that's what people want
to hear and it seems to be that's what
people want to hear
uh but I have to yeah I play a ukulele I
try to do everything I can to be
different and
um like I said I feel like the best
thing that I can bring to the table is
songwriting and the uh the catchy Melody
that's pretty much the only thing I'm
really good at everything else I just am
kind of okay with okay at and figure it
out you know wing it yeah sure um it
took me uh it took several people that I
admired telling me that I had a good
voice and that I should be singing for
me to feel comfortable doing it I was
still doing it but you know as a
professional singer it took a few people
being like no really you got to do this
for me to be comfortable with it because
you know they're in Nashville there's so
many amazing vocalists I can't compete
with Trisha Yearwood even she's an
amazing vocalist uh Carrie Underwood and
um but you know and I don't know how
many songs they're actually writing and
if they're uh you know if they're
you have a band that they're actually a
band I don't like these guys we actually
get together in practice where it's just
us we don't have management we don't
have a label we're doing it a Grassroots
style so they're like a family to me you
know and I think it's in the ground in a
15 passenger band yeah we only listen to
stand up comedy because we don't agree
on music by the way so we're just
listening to podcasts and specials yeah
but I think I think in in like
people who have you know voices that you
know Janice Joplin didn't have the uh
you know the greatest voice and people
that just it's what they're pushing out
of them is what you're what you
gravitate to uh if you know if you're
going to hear a singer per se be a
singer then you'd almost go to the Opera
because you're if you're gonna get rock
and roll you're gonna get somebody
that's really just
singing but they're also telling you
things and I think that's where you
where you land on the music that people
like it doesn't have to be yeah it's not
perfect
yeah you're right and I think we should
start changing radio stations
to just get the genre of things out
because there's been too many like when
my grandpa was playing music he only had
a few influences right because at that
time he like Django Reinhardt and Hank
Williams it was for his influences and
that was it so but for us we have so
many more influences right we're
listening to rock pop rap country reggae
you know like we're listening to
everything so to pinpoint an artist to
one genre these days you just have to
start making up genres so why not just
cut out the country radio station rock
station pop station right and just
call it a public radio station you know
just the radio station The Artist be
artists if you were doing your I if
everybody was doing music on their
computer or their phone or their iPad
whatever or their mix their mix would be
the perfect station for them
like whatever you put on your on on a
playlist that I get what you're saying
that's what you should be able to listen
to in the car where you might get some
you know Carol King and then Earth Wind
and Fire and you get some you know some
Johnny Cash and Willie Nelson and you
know uh um uh you know that kind of that
kind of stuff
yeah exactly I I mean I love uh I love
uh uh music
um
I always have uh do you think that do
you think that you'll ever get married
again
no no
no I don't uh uh how did you how did you
know I I you know I I was married for uh
17 years I didn't particularly find it
um very connected you know I was a I was
a very kind of disconnected person I
think my wife knew that uh at the time
but
um I don't think she understood that
um uh that there's some Darkness you
know uh when you marry somebody who's a
comedian and whether they become
successful or not
um uh there's still a little bit of some
issues there and I don't think you can
marry somebody that gets into this
profession and just because maybe
they're doing a show and it seems like
it's a nine to five that their
personality is nine to five
yeah and I got married really young I
got married because I didn't want my mom
to be mad at me for living with my
boyfriend out of wedlock you know so
at 19 that really bothered me that I was
disappointing her and then at 26 it
didn't bother me anymore I was like this
isn't working I just I would rather be
at peace yeah and and I did want to play
music and do and he didn't want that and
he to be fair he didn't sign up for that
right so
you know you just kind of we're uh
co-parenting pretty well I love his wife
she's a great stepmom to my kids and
she's a good person and exactly what he
wanted you know he wanted a woman who
would sit there and watch football and
cook and I just wasn't that girl I
wanted to go play music you know right
there's something yeah and travel and uh
and do all that uh uh um I would I would
assume that is probably uh difficult to
meet somebody I mean you have kids and
it's and you're out there right I think
it's very it's not like and I have to be
a mom yeah I have to be a mom and I I
also have to continue this career I've
started and I also started a podcast so
doing that along with the music there's
not a whole lot of time for somebody and
the
um the time that I tried dating someone
once since getting divorced and I felt
guilty in any situation I was in I felt
like I was being taken from the kids and
I felt guilty of that or I felt guilty
that he wanted me to hang out with him
and I couldn't because I was with the
kids and he was a musician as well so he
was gone I'd be home and free but he was
gone or then it it just didn't work out
and I realized I'm just waiting until my
kids are grown and or I mean who knows
what the universe does you can't plan
any plan and God laughs right but we I
just like I felt I don't want to do any
kind of serious relationship until my
kids are grown so I don't feel guilty as
a mom because I'm spending so much time
recording and playing music that I I'm
gonna feel better as a person and as a
mom if I'm here with them when I'm not
doing that yeah you know yeah yeah yeah
I get that I get that uh do you think
that longevity is connected to uh a
person's profession you think that maybe
because we travel that it's a little bit
the odds are a little bit higher than
opposed to Gill who's been married how
many years 50 51. 51 years uh that you
went to work you were a detective and
then you come back do you think do you
think that uh it has to do with uh you
think anything has to do with that
still laughing at the face she made a
dollar 51. yeah in 51 [ __ ] years
happily married
anybody says marriage is easy has never
been married so there there's you know
the bump speed bumps in the road over 51
years believe me and fortunately she's
the glue that's kept everything together
because
it's it's not easy
I think you can be a little bit uh um I
think that there's damages that you know
people go to therapy now it's very easy
you can get an app you know you can get
you can get quotes from different
religions or quotes from different
things but better help uh better help
but but also it's it's like some
sometimes
you know unfortunately when we're much
younger we're kind of like are formed
already and it's not fair I don't think
in life that
unbeknownst to you what happens to you
at seven eight nine ten and eleven
twelve thirteen is almost going into
this bank that is going to cause you
issues when you're growing up I think
that's it's unfair
it's unfair
yeah and you don't know at that age that
all of that is going to affect you later
on or the things that you're just
surviving you're in survival mode yeah
you're and you're a child you know
you're trying to have fun but also if
you lose a parent or if you lose a
sibling or if you lose
uh you know if somebody's mean to you or
they say things to you or you know if
you see things that you shouldn't see
they stay with you for your for your
whole life
and that's and that's a tough that's a
tough it's a tough thing to to to to
live with I think you know and and I
think music I think music is uh is for
us you know a part of all of that you
know part of
of of uh you know all of that stuff that
goes and makes you feel better I mean
you can be alone and have music and and
not not be alone
yeah sometimes I'm really sad I will
procrastinate turning music on because I
know it'll change my mood immediately or
you know and I'm just like no I want to
be mad and angry right now I won't even
pick up the guitar or I won't turn music
on because I want to be angry for a
minute because I know as soon as it's on
my mood will change it I think music and
laughter
is just as healing I I believe cannabis
is as well you know but I think music
and comedy laughter is just as healing
as actual medicine is because
we you have to stay uplifted and we have
to or or I have to I have to stay
uplifted I have to choose to be happy or
I will just lay in bed and make myself
sick you know and I don't want to die
yet so I couldn't agree with you more
it's just like you're choosing to die
I can't agree with you more laughter and
music I I refer to either one and when
I'm by myself
uh if I'm in the card predominantly
comedy on my on my car radio before it
was always music oldies but now it's
predominantly common and that's what I
need to get me through life is humor
yeah
if I'm with somebody I'll listen to
music because not everybody likes humor
but they all like music and but it is
it's healing for me and it's worked
yeah and oldies is a good music to
always turn to because most people enjoy
old days Tunes
um also the Beach Boys are really good
if you're feeling depressed especially
seasonal depression The Beach Boys help
with the spirits for sure and of course
my grandpa's music absolutely absolutely
makes me feel safe and nostalgic as a
little kid because it was just and all
that was played when I was growing up I
mean really all all of those guys your
grandfather included were really the
almost like the Mount Rushmore of of of
music you know where your grandfather
crossed all lines I mean I mean he did
him and you couldn't get two guys more
polar opposite than uh Enrique Iglesias
or or no Julio Iglesias and your
grandfather and to do such a beautiful
beautiful song I Loved Before to all the
To All the Girls I've Loved Before yeah
to all the girls I Loved Before I loved
that song yeah yeah yeah yeah
he wrote a song to all the girls that's
so funny to all of them there's so many
of them that are like hey that one's
about me that is
the uh uh um
um what's the best time of uh of the day
for uh for you
like I'm happy like I get most
ly no when it's your like your time like
we uh um do you get up early do you
sleep late or
I do both kind of you know like just
depends on what's happening in the day
of course when we're playing music it's
so it's late nights you know how it is
yeah the show business is always late
nights uh but I do find that I get way
more accomplished uh and more done if I
go to sleep early and get up early yes
you can get a lot done between five you
can get way more done between five and
eight then nine and one you know right I
don't know what it is but you it's just
the truth I I can't make I can't make
any sense of it but it's true what would
you say to people now because you know
there's so much uh uh information at
people's fingertips you know if somebody
like you like you said melodies or they
or they felt like they could write uh or
they felt like these things in their
mind just appeared you know these kind
of a connection of words or or musical
connections what would you say for
somebody to do if they if they felt like
they
um just had something hit hitting them
or musically touching them but they
weren't a musician per se
does that make sense
go for a drive go for a drive in the
back roads and then start thinking about
it in that case you could use a voice
memo to put down the information there's
something about uh this frontal lobe of
the brain and I don't even know if
that's right because I'm not that smart
but you're doing something and then the
other part of your brain is open because
you're doing something that's kind of
routine you don't need your full brain
there which sounds terrible because
you're driving let's use a different
analogy although driving works for me
but like when you're in the shower and
it's a routine you kind of know what
you're doing you can your brain will
zone out those are the times when those
you should be thinking about those
things and let those things pop in I was
gonna say the shower because yeah the
shower is uh is uh when things when
things happen have you have your
children shown any any signs of uh of uh
of musical ability
my boys do my boys are twins and they
play piano and they sing a little bit I
think if they really worked at it they
would be able to do it if they love
playing piano and they love the band AJR
that's their favorite band my daughter
is more of uh she wants to be a comedian
she wants she has an Instagram called
Vivian the comedian she wants to make
jokes and make people laugh but she's so
shy when it comes to talking to people
she doesn't know that she I I don't know
if that'll ever come to pass but she
does write the silliest jokes and she
she has this want to make people laugh
you know I think I started her first one
minute with her yeah it's not too bad
it's not too bad that's what I gotta say
I I think that's part of it I mean I I
couldn't speak uh I couldn't talk to
anybody uh
nobody actually showed me how to
introduce myself to anybody but I was
very shy you know open around my friends
but uh uh extremely introverted and uh
you know quiet and
um you know I used to go to The Comedy
Store when I was 18 years old and I
never imagined that you know why would
you go someplace to be bad for years and
still keep going that's if I had to look
back and look back at my early life I
was still in high school and I thought
why would I keep going back to a place
that that or places that I was bad at
and continue to go back I I don't know
the answer to that one
but it does you know it does it does
something to you uh so you know good on
your daughter I mean you know that I you
know more people now uh are finding uh
comedy through Instagram or Tick Tock uh
you know my daughter Mayan and I are
doing a show we sold the show to uh to
NBC and and uh the the woman that uh
that created this idea saw Mayan's uh
tick tocks and and said oh [ __ ] man
Lopez and George Lopez's daughter and
doing tick tocks and and now we're doing
uh a show at NBC and tick tocks are part
of the show
I love it that's going to be great yeah
they were they were at the tape and you
guys want the taping up yeah yeah yes
sir is it gonna be it yes all right
first thing I said he's got another
winner and yeah
yeah right there isn't a show with Tick
Tock in it yet no and and You Know It uh
it works you know and and in um you know
and and I'm fortunate to have
um the creator of my first show Bruce
Alford be the crew be one of my partners
in this show so I mean to be able to go
around twice
is uh is good
it must mean you're really talented and
smart and good at what you're doing it's
minimally stated yes have you thought of
uh have you thought of acting do you do
you see yourself as an actor
um yeah I could totally act I've done
um you know little things for music
videos and that sort of thing yeah I
could do it it's just not a big passion
of mine right but I've done comedy skits
and uh uh we just did a music video for
Ari shapir because we I don't know if
you know you know Ari shafir from New
York he has a podcast he does and we did
the theme song for it and uh so we
filmed a little music video and I got to
act a little in that
um that's the most recent thing but I
haven't been in movies right but I tell
you what though TV is the way to go
right because then you get a large
audience and get a lot of exposure I
think I think it is the I think it is
the way to go I remember Sam Sam Jackson
told me uh when you're a movie star
people see you on this big screen and
when they see you in person they go like
they back it up they're like oh that's
so-and-so and then when you're on TV
you're on a smaller screen and when they
see you they go they go up to you you
know they don't yeah yeah
do people always tell you um oh you're a
lot shorter than I thought you were
uh you know what yeah they do my Grandpa
gets that a lot my Grandpa gets that a
lot you're shorter than I thought you'd
be but I think he was taller back in the
day I think we all unfortunately like
you see somebody and they [ __ ] like
where's the other half oh man I think
you just I think you're back your spine
like compresses and you're like what the
[ __ ] happened the weight of the world
yeah but I I love you know I I I was at
a uh um
um a Grammy party and they introduced
the guy who wrote that's life that's
life and uh he stood up and he waved and
in the break I went over and I said did
you write that's life and he said I did
and I shook his hand I said I just want
to shake your hand I think it's a
beautiful song and I mean to be with the
guy who's an older guy that wrote that's
life is is is it's amazing to write a
song like that right like that came from
that that came from that that comes from
you that comes from them something that
that you will listen to Forever
was the writer also from New York Phil
when I would work I was working at a bar
a few years ago and they had a
songwriter night and every single person
that came in to sing a song that they
wrote it was a huge hit
but you just did you know that it was
this guy that wrote it right and it was
just some regular person
and I I was blown away it was every
Tuesday night in Nashville and I mean I
can't even think of the hit stop me just
huge hits and but you know the person
who made them big wasn't singing it it
was the person who wrote it right and um
I just remember thinking that was really
cool and how cool they were and just
regular people you know they weren't
just very Nashville I guess you know
just the songwriters that live life and
just go to Kroger like everyone else and
they're not living in the big fancy
places but uh you always
that shocked me when I was a kid I
thought everyone who sang the song wrote
it right yeah I thought that was how it
worked and then obviously that's not how
it works at all I found out my grandpa
didn't write Poncho and Lefty two weeks
ago
town spanzan I found that out two weeks
ago oh yeah wow
yeah I mean
it's all I mean it's all really
I hope that you know because you know
kids are kids are so into like uh things
that are quick you know on their phones
and all that that at some point that uh
um I think it's different because songs
are music is different now it means
different things to people that that
they they appreciate
um
uh that that music because I think don't
don't more artists come like there's
more genres now you know rap and and
different types of things but that kids
would uh look at it as the art that it
is and not just the song that it is
yeah I've come up with little bitty 30
second Tick Tock songs that I think
could go would do well go viral yeah
whatever do well on the tick tock so I
actually thought of
recording it you know recording this
song looping it to where it's like a
full song Right putting it up somewhere
just for an experiment right just put it
up on Spotify and then as a different
person I'm not even going to say the
name just in case I do this then use the
song on Tick Tock and try to get it to
go but not as Rayland or RaeLynn would
do it but it wouldn't the song wouldn't
be raelynn's song it would be another
pseudo name whatever right
and just to see because I'm just
watching the tick tocks you can kind of
see what they're into and literally it's
only 30 seconds to a minute you don't
need a whole lot for them to be into it
and then I've just seen a lot of bands
blow up from it or artists and I've
actually thought of spending time of
recording these 30 second ideas looping
it and then trying to do it on Tick Tock
just to think outside the box and try
another thing to get some sort of
exposure I think you should I think you
should yeah I think that could
definitely work I don't I don't follow
you on Tick Tock but I think I will
right now he's about to
yeah I've heard people who like listen
to it listen to tick tock and uh that
big song in in Kanto we don't talk about
Bruno won all sorts of awards or
whatever and I watched that with a
friend and she was like oh wait I
recognize this part of the song I
recognize this part of the song I
recognize this part of the song but she
had no idea it all came from the same
song so it's crazy that sort of like
Snippets that people can sort of latch
onto when it's you know in like a 15
second clip that goes viral yeah I think
there's a ton of potential and you have
to put it somewhere so that people can
go find it right because if it's just on
Tick Tock I don't think it's gonna do
very well it has to be on YouTube or
Spotify or something for them to be able
to go and listen
is that her I don't know what is what is
your your Tick Tock handle what does it
handle oh
yeah what is it we'll uh we'll follow
you right now
what [ __ ] connection went out oh
what now uh why are you on the road now
are you doing shows
I'm home right now we have a show in
Nashville next week at the Five Spot and
on Wednesday night and then
Saturday we play in Owensboro Kentucky
no I mean come on that yeah
and then yeah we have a couple shows in
October one in November just doing these
one-offs right now it's kind of been
like that since the pandemic since we've
got now it's not a whole lot of a big
run it's just little one-offs oh we did
it okay we've just followed you on tick
tock
I want to see if I'm not already
I mean you're such a good writer I think
uh I think you have to do that right
don't you feel okay
I will I'm gonna do it I yeah George
Lopez told me to do it I'm doing it
you're right here first
yeah all right well
um I love music that that's that's it I
mean I always loved uh you know
um
like you know uh have what have you seen
like uh I saw a kid have you seen kid
what were your what was your first your
first concerts that you went to
were you gonna say kiss I saw a kiss
yeah a lot I'm friends still friends
with those guys like you know I know
they're wrapping it up and they're you
know 70 year old guys in uh demon outfit
and a star over his eye but
to me it's oh I think it's all I mean I
think you know really as you get older
man it's like when those dudes hang it
up
they're gonna hang something up that's
been around my whole life
yeah but they won't have to they will
just get guys to come in and paint their
face
it'll continue on forever and ever I
think they were saying that they were
planning on on trying to do that that
they could they could they are they are
right so they could get four other guys
kiss the franchise yeah uh and
um you know I I was my first concert I
went to in 1976 and then little did I
know that a few years ago before the
pandemic I was flying back from Columbus
uh Ohio with them on their plane sitting
across from Paul Stanley and I said is
this is this it is this it and he's like
uh yeah I think it is you know I've been
hurt so much and he started going
through the uh I I he goes I tore my
bicep off my muscle off and my hip had
replaced and my feet and my back is a
problem and you and you're like watching
this guy from the first concert to now
saying you know I think it is kind of a
wrap for us that all of the injuries
that he sustained but also I mean has
toured the world
um in this kind of outfit that has
become you know known around around the
world and I mean there is there is
something too uh
um a musician like you're a musician
that there is a uh respect for the
hierarchy I would say you know
yes yes I took my kids to the KISS
concert here in Nashville in 2019 or
2018 I think it was yeah and they loved
it and they were at the time they were
probably 11 and at nine you know I mean
they were pretty young and they loved it
yeah
um and
yeah they were still doing it but yeah
I've talked to Gene
um I have a connection with him in
Nashville and he
he told me he was like yeah we're just
gonna get guys to jump in literally 100
years from now kiss could still be
happening that'd be that'd be amazing
you still have it yeah I'm amazed right
now
cause I'm thinking about going The
Temptations all the original is gone now
there you see and they've still got
concerts going on nothing as big as kiss
but they've what you're talking about
they still continue doing
I didn't know that that's neat you think
they could have a white Temptation no
it couldn't be like a Jackie Robinson of
Temptations like a white dude that would
break the color barrier no and be like
what the [ __ ] is it it's a Temptation up
there what's that right it would have to
be a very special uh type of singer but
you know even actors like you know
um the guy from Starsky and Hutch
David's Soul had a song or or John
Travolta sang back in the in the 70s
like you know they would try to get a TV
star to to uh to go out and and sing and
kind of tour uh David Cassidy of course
you know the huge but also uh you know
some other uh some others Ricky Nelson
Ricky Nelson
oh yeah my cousin he's not really my
goodness yeah
but uh but uh Leonard did you get into
Leonard Skinner I did I didn't think I
didn't think of them as I still like
them I didn't think of the Confederate
flag as anything uh um back then as as
anything I think you know
sometimes we yeah sometimes we're
looking for [ __ ] to I mean you could
look at everything and find something
wrong with everything because everything
can't be good if you're looking for
negative you'll find it but I I love the
I mean the fact that those guys used to
write back there in some hot house and
they would sit in the hot house and then
uh uh Ronnie Van zand would would go on
the go fishing on the on the lake and
come back with lyrics I got him you know
and and I mean however however it works
it's it's beautiful that it's even
attempted because you know how difficult
it is to to write but also to have have
something be
come from you and just
fill the space with make people you know
feel things that they like you said that
they were sad and up and happy because
that I think that's a little bit of uh
that's life
yeah and his fishing was my driving on
the back roads you know he had to go do
something
to get his brain working and let let
that flow in you know uh uh I think you
know Rayland has something very very
um astute that people don't do on
Sundays back in the in the 70s maybe you
guys did it where your family would say
we're going for a ride and on Sunday you
you went for a ride like around around
town like you went to wherever like
downtown maybe you went downtown and ate
something and then came back but you
just got in the car and went
for a ride nobody nobody does that
anymore nobody does that anymore the gas
prices
at six I go the long way home yeah you
go a different different way
a different way home
well I hope that when you come to Los
Angeles that that uh that we're able to
go see you like that we know that you're
going to be here and uh uh I think it
would be great to be able to see you
yes thank you
um I will I don't know when I'll be able
to get out to LA but when I am I'll make
sure you guys know and you'll of course
have your name on the list yeah I hope
well you know I I admire you because
um
I know
um you know uh to have music in your
family is is one thing but also to have
uh children and to want to be a mother
but then consider yourself an artist
um is
um
uh much more honorable than uh than your
musical ability to be a good mom
thank you and I'm teaching them to
follow their dreams too that's you know
yeah and that is uh to follow their
dreams is absolutely absolutely
um uh essential for any child and it
just became essential for children not
not when I shut that my brother would be
like shut up
I said I want to be a comedian I'm
funnier than you get the [ __ ] out of
here
I didn't know how could somebody be mean
so fat hey hey George what you never
wanted to be thin
she has some roast cups laughs
George let me ask you that you won't get
mad uh uh I don't know how do you know
I'm not gonna get mad so you never
wanted to to to try to be something
[Music]
Look at me now no Grandma I didn't and
then they [ __ ] die they [ __ ] died
before you are something son of a [ __ ]
if you're gonna talk [ __ ] you gotta at
least hang around long enough to see
what happens
yeah that is amazing advice that too if
you're gonna talk [ __ ] you gotta be
around long enough to see what happens
well God bless you and thank you for
um uh being with us today
same God bless you guys yeah thank you
so much it was a real pleasure thank you
we didn't even introduce her
oh yeah who joined us today on the
podcast amazing singer songwriter
founder of the Rayland Nelson band
Rayland Nelson
oh nice thank you guys thank you thanks
for helping me get the word out I
written it out absolutely we'll talk to
you
bye bye